I saw um two girls one cup and I kind of
[__] me up a little bit in a good way
kind of like recently he got horny yeah
that's weird I was like pretending to
throw up but afterwards I was like you
still got chubbed that was fine he left
immediately went to a Breyers
[Music]
anybody here a fan of the Mars chocolate
bar oh the actual Mars bar and that's
like 1950s ain't nobody eat that yeah I
don't think any pizzas anymore huh you
know what's the worst bar ever it's
caramel which one Crunch bar what no you
guys are losers
there's a [__] ball no one wants a
crunchbox no I have a Nostalgia for them
though yeah I love them you're not gonna
go to the store and buy a whole king
size yes but they're not bad but no but
they're not good and you gotta if you
get a small mini one you're like oh okay
I got a Milky I always like the crispy
ones that have the rice crackers and
stuff no
extra Dynamic roses texture Dynamic all
right out of all of the bars what's your
top three it's not Crunch and now you
look like a dummy
it's not crunch what's your number
[Laughter]
anything else other than crunch yeah
yeah no I was thinking more like the
Mars Bar the [__] uh Baby Ruth the
Almond Joy Baby Ruth wait you think
almond Joy's good no no no I'm saying
that the category it has to be like an
actual bar just wigs count yeah Snickers
the Twigs Almond Joy and Crunch bars are
literal trash Crunch bars are bombs are
nasty crunch Almond Joys isn't that the
coconut one yeah I like that hey Crunch
bars with ice cream in the middle bro
you throw ice cream anywhere and it's
[__] good but I remember those those
are good those are the only Crunch bars
are bomb anyways give your top three
what's your number one though Crunch bar
no you're lying you're lying you look
like you're lying on people you're lying
to the people Anthony looking there
you're like you bring me a crush on this
one I'll eat it fully I'll eat it too
I'm [__] talking fat but don't lie to
the people I'm not lying to the people
have you had a nutritious
that sounds that sounds like
discontinued take five bro you guys are
crazy about to take five right now 99
Cent Story okay let me bring all that
comments from the Zoomers or you are out
of pocket crunch is pretty good though
all right what about it Mars oh yeah
KitKat Mars Bars yeah all right their
company has actually just been fined
after two workers almost drowned in one
of their tanks of chocolate I've seen
that movie I want a drown in it
wait didn't this happen in The Simpsons
the
the comic book guy was like best pose
ever and he wanted to like freeze and it
happened in Willy Wonka right it happens
in general but I mean common common yeah
this is usually it didn't happen to you
um two workers fell into a vat of
chocolate and almost drowned how does
that happen it was actually last year
because they don't know how to swim yeah
this is the one we did this before and
we said it was because it was a 90s
fight and they were on the railing
wrestling because they both went they'd
come out that's why you gotta have a
lifeguard next to the pool of chocolate
and pull them out did we talk about this
where they had the uh fine settle is
that why this is new news I think it's
like this is a development yeah but we
did do the initial went back in the day
yeah yeah basically they were only fine
well what do you think that they would
be fine for something like that someone
died no no they almost got drowned the
two got fined they didn't get fined the
Mars Factory got fun was there a lasting
injury no safety bar no handwriting I
now hate all chocolate lasting injury
what's the lawsuit dude you've Fallen
chocolate and you come out smiling come
on that sounds like a kid's dream they
for real almost drowned though they had
to like come in because they couldn't
come out of it so they had to come in
and drill a hole at the bottom of the
vet and [__] drain it and then they
can pull the pull the people out but
they didn't die these guys are losers
they need to have bars like bars not
candy bars but they could hold on to
metal bars this is very confusing but
they didn't break a bone they didn't die
that's no lawsuit they had a nice little
fondue [__] that's a dream come true
it's like you fell that's like the
biggest gaslighting though it's like hey
you fell in a [__] batch of chocolate
stop complaining everybody would love
that yeah I got a bruise from all the
gold bars you scrounged me and I'm rich
now oh no you drowned the [__] oh no
like that's what you want
no no lawsuit two thousand bucks
apparently the occupational safety and
health administration AKA OSHA said the
workers were not authorized to work in
the tanks and were not trained on the
proper safety procedures for the
equipment so I don't know if it was a
matter of them just following they were
Guatemalan or if they were like
intentionally supposed to be in these
tanks to do certain maintenance work
this is why Willy Wonka got Oompa
Loompas is because he didn't want to
humans anymore he's like Oompa Loompas
are chill yeah you know are you
dehumanizing Oompa Loompas no but that's
exactly why he got Oompa Loompas because
they're good workers workers were like
suing them I gotta go workers were
stealing uh Secrets yeah but Oompa
Loompas they're loyal to the soil huh
they're loyal yeah they're and they
don't work to the soil that what they
grow out of I don't know where oopa
lipas come from they come from the
jungle I got a confession what you know
Oompa Loompas literally gave me
nightmares they're scary bro they're
really [__] scary I don't know I do
remember feeling sad when the song came
out and I was really upset I didn't like
the song because I knew something bad
was gonna happen oh for the kids Willy
Wonka was weird bro it's really creepy
it's super the whole thing they're
making a new one right they've already
made a new one no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no one I don't
know if uh what's his name I guess Willy
Charlie Charlie no I think Charlie's
taking over now
[Music]
the one that's coming right now oh
there's a new one yeah so it's like a re
it's like a but I think Charlie's the
guy now I might be wrong there but there
is a new new one coming oh and Charlie
becomes I think but I might be wrong
there but there is a new one it's gonna
be called Wonka that's a it's a new
prequel to Charlie and the Chocolate all
right so it's in the back due for
release this year a prequel how much do
they get fined though nothing oh it's
how Willy Wonka fourteen thousand
dollars okay plus nothing to them that's
nothing wrong
million dollar company being fined for
white bothered they're like oh [__] two
of your [__] workers just fell in a
vat of chocolate they almost drowned oh
[__] it's like how much does it cost me
fourteen thousand dollars all right they
need a counter suit what were those two
fools going in there anyways we're
trying to [__] have a secret love
affair that's exactly what they were
saying this is a secret love affair for
sure I'm saying they shouldn't have had
the Valentine's Day chocolate makes a
good Lube is that what you're telling
them
strawberries in there and camouflage
yeah I never understood why people like
to have sexual things with chocolate
because it looks like you're doing [__]
play and also sticky dude
you're into Scott see yeah I am I have
to agree with everything these guys say
now that's crazy like some not
specifically scat but close watch just
butthole play I saw um two girls one cup
and it kind of [__] me up a little bit
in a good way kind of like recently he
got horny yeah that's weird I was like
pretending to throw up but afterwards I
was like you still got chubbed this [__]
was fine he left immediately went to a
Briars
for chocolate ice cream like I used to
hate chocolate ice cream until I watched
uh two girls one cup and I really got
into chocolate
I don't I'm not into [__] player he
decided to stay brown belt forever yeah
you won't ever upgrade for the record
I'm not in the ship no I don't I don't
like I don't like milk chocolate though
I don't love chocolate I don't like milk
I only eat dark chocolate milk
chocolate's disgusting mixed with some
[__] so my uh not [__] but mixed with
some like vanilla ice cream I do like it
mixed better yeah but like a Neapolitan
yeah or I just can't eat like just
chocolate like that's why I like Reese's
peanut butter yeah same same hey guys
dude it's yo comment below crunch all
right comment below and let them know
that it's not even the top five candy
did Ryan say he hasn't watched two girls
top five I really like Crunch bars Ryan
just admitted to me that he's never seen
two girls one cup and last time I said
that these [__] [__] are bullies
maybe watch it I didn't watch the top
top Ryan's the director of that video I
I watched I was the light producer yeah
some weird or stuff like that like with
cereal hey what's in the Babe Ruth
there's one with the funnel
honest top three
if I were to get candy bars classic
candy bars Reese's cow oh yeah okay uh
I'm gonna for sure do the Twix yep Twix
is good Twix for sure you're okay with
that yeah uh and Reese's counts I think
Reese's I think it counts then I'm gonna
throw Reese's in there
they have re-sticks I know but in the
shape of the rapper is a bar okay yeah
and then third would probably they'll
probably be Crush bar okay
Milky Way thanks those are for church
milk church it's like a Twix bar no
one's ever said chocolate gold those are
like Halloween handouts you know what I
mean they're like the first thing bro if
your face fillers no bro if you go to
any kid's house and they got the variety
bag crunch is the last one chosen not at
my house you saved the best for last bro
oh you saved that for moms that [__] is
a Tootsie Roll that's all Apple was the
last thing ski waves are always left
behind though really no one likes milk I
feel like milky Way's top 10. they're
good they're good but they're Left
Behind not Crunch bars speakers better
than Milky Way yeah yeah same to me
they're saying okay you know what's a
low-key hitter a score bar what the heck
is that that was that what's a score bar
with the k s k o r which one with
pretzels five sorry
one of my favorite [__] Toblerone
that's good that doesn't count that's
like Asian moms at Costco foreign
dude I always enjoyed Ghirardelli's with
the caramel inside yeah
or what's the Swiss Mountain looking one
the Swiss Mountain looking it's on the
label oh the Andes The Mint one no no no
no just chocolate oh or with caramel in
it it's like that fancy one pinky up
chocolate oh I don't know you've had it
it's got like a mountain I like a dinner
mint I like those those Cliff Bars no no
no no no no no similar label though
there's a mountain yeah it's not Andy's
no oh look that [__] up dog we need to
figure that one out that sounds too
familiar Snickers in there I love
Snickers it's Snickers they made fun of
me for liking that Snickers with a glass
of milk what was the one where in high
school kids will go around selling
chocolate bars and they had they were
like almost like little
um oh and it's in a triangle yeah
and there's three kinds one is like a
crunch where it's got the Rice Krispies
one has caramel in it one's like dark
chocolate what's almonds yeah the
tiniest [__] almonds dude almonds and
chocolate is kind of horseshit too
those go good together box and chocolate
are the only reasons why I eat seeds
thank you thank you for that chocolate I
don't I don't I don't I don't wait you
don't like nuts and chocolate I'll eat
it but it's definitely not like the
ghost so okay what's your goat what's
your what's your what's your chocolate
eater try tweaks Reese's
and crunch baby there's a [__] nuts
in The Recess right there there's no
that's a peanut it's a fake peanuts it's
peanut butter it's not even real peanut
no shot and Reese's that's just bright
orange what so what kind of peanuts
y'all that's the wrapper all these
people that are allergic could have been
eating it all this time but likely it
says may contain peanuts it's a peanut
sauce though if it was real peanut it'd
be like peanuts it says it's peanut
powder it's fake peanut powder no but
there's there's like remnants of peanuts
in there
ribs nah there's no chunks what kind of
[__] expired ass Reese's y'all eat
it's solidified back I'll say something
though real quick I've been liking the
Reese's fins
no the ratio is Reese's eggs olives oh
what oh no you're wow Reese's eggs is
the best candy bar ever created
the reason hey y'all never celebrated
Easter yeah bro I've never seen that
before no shot you've seen the Christmas
tree oh the reason's Christmas do you
guys not have holidays in L.A Mike the
Reese's the Christmas tree they got they
got nuts in here yeah it's like
Christmas tree eggs thin bars crunch
right I've never seen what you're
talking about crunch is so bad
have you had the crunch bites that uh
bites are better that's what I'm saying
[Music]
foreign